let's go ahead and get started welcome
everyone so as most you know today is
the day that we start for the next three
weeks I think it is the presentations
from our summer interns who have been
working hard all summer and hopefully
having a good time and enjoying
themselves and so we usually we have the
faculty who's the mentor introduced so I
will turn over the microphone to Karen I
just want to warn people and I guess I
have to apologize forever the third
speaker is today someone scheduled the
meeting that I unfortunately could not
change so I need to leave about 1225 so
I may miss the end of the last talk and
it's not out of lack of interest or
anything it's just that unfortunately
someone schedules a meeting but we
actually have 90 minutes so take your
time and ask questions and we'll look
forward to hearing what what's happened
so I will turn it over to Karen I thank
you this has been a great opportunity
for us to work together and on a couple
of efforts so some of you may know that
dr. Nelson and I have been have
developed a tool to help patients
understand whether they're at average
risk or above average risk for breast
cancer
and it's also a decision aid so some of
you may have seen some of the
presentations or seen us at research
week but we have the opportunity this
summer to have the tool translated into
Spanish and I was going to be speaking
about that today
and then go Cole is going to tell us
about his early work in trying to
integrate our tool which currently
resides outside of epic to talk to epic
so you're gonna hear about that that
early effort as well so I will now turn
it over I believe IO is first
all right so we really quickly before IO
goes I'd like to just give it a give a
brief overview or sort of introduction
so thank you all for being here today
and allowing us to present in front of
you I mean it's been a wonderful summer
and you know the work has been great and
really have we've learned a lot truly so
thank you and you know over the past 10
or so weeks myself and I have been
working on different sort of projects
but related to the same memo screen
probably the dr. Eden dr. Nelson have
worked on and so you know the following
presentation we hope to we hope to
describe what we've done maybe maybe
share some reflections some insight and
and things like that so I oh I think
headed off to you
the work we've done for the past few
weeks so a brief introduction to mount
of screen malice screen was a tool an
app developed by dr. Aden dr. Nelson to
help women over the age of or 40 or
older with decision regarding a breast
cancer screening for women between the
age of 40 and 50 whether they should get
screening done or not and for women
older than 50 how often they should get
breast cancer screenings this is what
the page the web page looks like as you
can see it's simple but very helpful as
I'll show you so what is now screen now
screen is composed of two different
parts one which is the risk assessment
the risk assessment consists of asking
the person about their personal history
their family's history brca1 and 2 which
Gokul will later kind of talk about and
just in general how at risk they are for
developing breast cancer and this is
then used for the second portion which
is the decision aid and that uses the
risk how it risk they are their
preferences on on how they feel about
screening and what their must scared of
and this is to help facilitate a
conversation between a physician and the
patient about a breast cancer and this
is what the title page the cover page
from a screen looks like
so what was my job in all this my job I
was searching for the right word and
while translating does encompass some
portions what I was doing I worked that
I found that really encompassed what I
did this summer was meta phrasing and
verses so here I have the definitions
for meta phrase the first definition
that I found was to translate
especially literally and so that's very
important we have to know how to
translate something however more so to
what I was doing and when I what really
was important in this project that I did
was to manipulate that the text so as to
get the point across and that was
something that was surprisingly
difficult and so I'd like you all to
take 10 seconds or so and just look at
this image and think about the different
objects that you may see or what you see
in this image and so some of you might
have seen fairy some of you might have
seen a hummingbird some of you might
have seen seen a mustache a butterfly -
Lions there are a variety ways this can
be interpreted and this is the problem
that I ran into dr. Eden when she began
working with mammal screening as she
developed that adapt
she had a design graphics or images to
convey the message and this was one of
the images that she talked about two
weeks ago that they that was
misinterpreted at first they had one
person instead of two and that person
had on the left side a slowly growing
cancer tumor and on the right side one
that grew quickly and there was a person
that interpreted that as well on the
left side on the right side it'll grow
slowly and on the left side it'll grow
quickly and so they had to make sure and
use two different people and show that
it could be on either side and that
really the point that they were trying
to get at was that there were two
different things you know you can't
really tell just by the place there that
was on the body whether crystal they're
not and so here's a sample problem of
really how that related to my work of
translating the text
so this is one of the portions that a
patient first encounters a portion
subtext that the patient first
encounters when they take the mammal
screen
decision made and so it says a breast
cancer screening decision aid for women
40 and older it's just a description for
Wolfman screen is when this was
automatically translated the translation
that came up was una this he's shown the
extent that kind of the hope I mean I
could read it but I don't know how many
of you understand Spanish and so as I
was looking at this this is not the
right translation and so I went ahead
and translated it and this translation
is a lot longer and why is that well
that's because the literal translation
each word does have a little translation
however when you use the word for
example a decision made there's no
actual word in Spanish to describe that
and so you have to describe the overall
use of it and how a person would use it
rather than just using the literal word
translations and so what the first
automatic translation chose actually
means is help to take a decision about
breast cancer screening one in four
years or older and that's I mean it's
helped but like it's not doesn't really
describe what it is it's kind of get
some unit cost but it it loses some
context and depending on who you are it
can be ambiguous and that's what I was
aiming to do as I was translating get
rid of the ambiguity and so here's the
process I worked a lot with the content
manager which is a repository that has
all the content that is shown in the app
here is the the English version and
here's the Spanish version that I
translated one of the hardest parts with
working with this was definitely having
code within the actual text and so I had
to make sure that for example bolded
words
had the right emphasis in Spanish than
in English and so like especially for
images and that was something that I
struggled with that and working with
Excel because Excel isn't particularly
too friendly with writing down stuff so
and well it would be great if I was done
there but no after going through the
first draft you have to go back and
double-check yourself and for example
one of the things that I found was
something as simple as the button to
turn it into Spanish was misspelled and
so I had to go back and make note of
that so that that could be that could be
a change that our program could take
care and so this is just like the the
first couple of examples of stuff that I
had to go back and review and we're done
right well no so in addition to that I
then had to go and find people that
spoke Spanish so in Spanish there are
lots of dialects there's those that are
from Spain and they speak their own
dialect there are those from even from
within different regions of Mexico that
speak different dialects Central
Americans speak different Peru Ricans
Cubans Brazil known opposition when
speaking something else but Argentinians
the etc they all have their own dialects
their own versions of Spanish and they
don't all understand the exact same
phrase and so I went ahead and tried to
find as wide of a scope as I could out
in the community and thankfully I'm dr.
Eden already had some sort of interview
guidelines that she used with the
Spanish version to make sure like the
images were conveying the right message
and so I'm translating those and using
them as a kind of structure for the
interviews that I held with the new
people or the new
interviewees really help me make it more
efficient so thankfully I think I'm not
wait did I forget the screenshot of the
fish I know it's there all right
okay so this is what I ended up that
this was the final product much like the
original version in English my aim was
really to keep the format to keep the
original intent but just translated
smash and make sure that the message
that was originally in English was also
conveyed in the Spanish version so now
now that I've talked about the work that
we've done for the past ten weeks let's
reflect a little bit on on these on the
work that I've done so at first I
thought this was going to be very
straightforward however I encountered
some problems so first well the first of
those problems was gain a clear message
I'm making sure that the that the person
was was getting the message across that
or not that person was getting the
scratch that the writing that was
translating the translations were
getting the point across and that was
very hard well not very hard but it was
definitely took a lot more effort than I
originally anticipated and the second I
guess conflict no the second thing that
made it hard for me to really do it as
fast as I could of where I wanted to was
I'm having a programmer that was not
part of the OHSU because I couldn't
really upload the new content as I was
editing it and so I had to wait to for
them to update the website and so
sometimes people would point out the
same mistakes and keep track of which
mistakes were already noticed and which
ones weren't was a little hard and so
what did I learn well I learned that you
always have to click Save when you're
working with Microsoft Office I don't
know the hard way I learned that you
always have to double-check
that I had to do lots of that and then
most importantly I learned that the
department of medical informatics and
clinical epidemiology is more than just
working with data and it really does
help connect people with people so I'll
hand it off to Gokul who will proceed to
explain how Qbert with code that's all
that all I know all right well thank you
I oh I'm sure your work is going to help
ma'am a screen in fact so many more
people than it would have previously so
seriously thank you for your work and
well I did the data integration part of
of this presentation and what I worked
on over the summer in large part was how
do I get data from one place and put it
into another and in this case it would
be memo screen and you know in
approaching this sort of problem that
the question that I asked myself going
in was alright well how do I access the
appropriate patient information that I
need from an EHR and how do I then put
that into memo screen and so this was a
sort of question that that guided my my
project throughout the summer and so in
order to answer this question there are
certain processes that I had to that I
had to take and certain paths that I had
to go through to get to where I you know
to get to where I finished and to create
something meaningful and so as an
overview what I did could be classified
under three basic categories so first I
had to gain an understanding of an EHR
and EHR systems and see how I could use
that to then code and and do something
meaningful and after that I had to learn
how to use fire and fire tools things
like smart on fire to actually interact
with an EHR in a way that I needed it to
and lastly after doing those two things
I need to use smart on fire to actually
pull the patient data that I wanted and
put it into a program now things like
EHR and inspire on fire might be might
be some terms that are foreign to do
some of my fellow interns here so I'm
going to clarify those don't worry and
so just bear with me here and so first
like well what does an EHR well it's
literally just if you took all those
papers that that physicians the rights
stuff down in and you put it online I
mean that's exactly what any Atari is
it's just a place where all of this
patient data is stored and centralized
and so this is what an EHR is and for my
project this was exactly where I needed
to gather data from I mean this was this
this goldmine if you will of a patient
data that I could use for to put in a
memo screen but as much as it is a
goldmine different EHR platforms work
different from one another so how
something is stored in epoch for example
oh it just use EHR might be different
from how something is stored on a Cerner
EHR and and different EHRs have
different criteria for all sorts of
different aims so I mean this is a
difficulty that that many people were
thinking about and that's where actually
my next slide comes into play is
something called fire and so in order to
combat the variability between EHRs a
standard was developed fast healthcare
and operability resources whereby you
can pull at least in theory you can pull
information from different EHRs easily
because they're all stored in a similar
way and fire resource types and so
basically how it works is there's a fire
resource which has a standard set of
behaviors and you can use that to then
do things right and if it was a
straightforward as it sounded well I
wouldn't need like the rest of my
presentation honestly but again I mean
that this alone we could talk about well
despite the fact that fire claims the
standardized things really it doesn't do
that you know I'll talk about more why
but just right off the bat fire doesn't
actually tell you how to use fire and
that's a bit problematic so researchers
from from the Boston Children's Hospital
and and the Department of thing
informatics at Harvard actually created
a tool to use fire and use it
effectively and it was called smart on
fire and it actually tells you how you
use fire how do you use it meaningfully
what tools are there you know it's it
standardizes things in a way it's it it
created gives you methods to
authenticate data you know it gives you
methods for launching fire related apps
and it makes the whole process so much
easier and so this was a tool that I
leveraged in my project actually to
create an app
and what you'll see here is just this is
one of the functions that comes with
spot on fire it's an OAuth tool and
basically this is how you authorize an
app to pull data from an HR and such and
so with all of that said you know after
kind of gaining an understanding of EHRs
and and sort of tools like smart on fire
I had to then actually code something
and create something meaningful and so I
had to figure out how to go about and do
that right and so I basically had a four
step approach to going about and doing
this and first I need to classify the
questions that were in mammoth screen
into their respective fire resource
types and so well if you take for
example the first question up there this
was a question that's asked on on Manus
Chris actually the first question it's
do you have signs of breast disease now
and it lists some of these things and
well what type of a fire resource would
that be stored under well I mean I'll
talk more about this difficulty just
just in a bit but I came to the
conclusion it could be stored under an
observation it could also be stored
under a condition but we'll get to that
later after classifying different
questions into their respective research
types I had to then gain a developer's
license to each our sandbox because for
whatever reason these companies are
awfully protective of their EHRs and so
this was this was one of my troubles and
after doing that I had to then create a
server because all this is web-based
right so fire EHRs the mamuh screen
these are all web-based things that need
to pull information and put them in the
other place so you have to create a
server to do that and then after that
I'd struggle a lot and beg developers
for code sometimes shamelessly but I
think it was worth it in the end and so
let's let's break what you know those
steps down just a little bit more and
first when you when you have to classify
a resource right so as a layman as
someone who's not a medical practitioner
there's already like a lot of doubt for
me I don't know how a physician is going
to classify something like a like a
tumor found in the breast I mean it
could be a condition it could be an
officer who knows it could be an issue
so I I already don't know a lot of these
things because I'm not a fist I don't
practice and so
I had to basically roughly estimate what
I thought would be reasonable like would
they do this I don't know but this is
what I'm putting down
and so after going through that for most
of these questions I generally felt kind
of confident about what I did and then I
proceeded to develop a sorry acquire
developers license or at least I tried
to but I didn't quite but thankfully
Cerner and I'm not advertising Cerner in
any way but Cerner was the only platform
that I could use in EHR sandbox for free
so if anyone's thinking of developing
the future
Cerner has different fire sandboxes that
work really well and so I went onto
Cerner I used their their sandbox and it
worked really well and so I had to then
go create a server I was using or at
least I started out using two different
servers but I quickly defaulted to one
of them because me tea or the one that
dr. or will actually showed me how to
use and thank you so much for that
I actually was too complex for me so I
just use a simpler one one that did a
lot of work for me which is replied that
I T recommend it again to anyone
developing in fire and so here we so you
know here we get to the actual coding
part right so here's what you know what
did I do
how did I go about it what were the
challenges well an observation about
this entire process was there's a lot of
high-level like discussion about how to
use fire how do you smart on fire how to
pull things together but like when it
comes to actually doing it there's not
that much stuff out there
and we'll touch on that later but this
was the biggest challenge I think to my
actual coding but going through the
process that there were three pieces of
code that I would that I would you know
recommend or emphasize to any developer
once we could have fire app would be the
three following the search method is one
that allows you to search any sort of
data in I mean in your app and you can
pull pick any sort of data that you need
the fetch shell method is very similar
but it allows you to gather and it like
the data from an entire resource and
then you have the fire that authorized
method which is how you get tokens and
how you you go from an EHR to get
patient information and stuff so all
that might not mean much to you or it
may I don't know but if you are going to
code I mean this is
these are like the best methods I think
and again well I had later on in the
project I got a lot of help from the
Cerner fire developers group which was
very helpful and so alright so I would
say going into this project I was very
confident that I'd be able to do
something good and that's not because I
was confident in my own skills but it
was because I was confident in the fact
that there were going to be a lot of
resources so I was 50 percent right my
skills weren't there but the resources
also weren't there
and so this posed a challenge as you can
see I thought you know I'd be able to do
something good create an excellent app
help tremendously with me on the screen
and such wait oh actually hold on pause
really quickly I actually need to show
you the app I almost forgot about that
let me show you the app really quick
before I discuss it but so here this is
the reply Todai tea that I was talking
about and so if we are to launch my fire
app from there just example fire app
imagine that your patient logging in to
uh to a fire you click login here so now
you have to log into your to your EHR so
you type your stuff here and your
password username whatever you sign in
and the the program asks if you want to
connect your your app to your to your
EHR and you click allow access and now
this program is very simple when it just
gets your conditions but yeah there are
a lot of errors here but that's more
just my program not pulling pulling
information that's not there but here we
get you know this patient has essential
hypertension hypertension you know
different things and so it just pulls
conditions in it and it shows them this
is very simple program but
yeah I mean that was my program and and
again it's it's a bit it's a bit
simplistic it's not quite what I wanted
to do and I'll talk about that in a
little bit but I thought I'd be able to
create an excellent app well I think
this app is alright it was not as
excellent as I thought it was going to
be so this in large part I think was due
to the fact that like there isn't a lot
of resource out there for fire app
developers so just it's a really new
thing
there isn't much stuff out there and
that makes it challenging to to actually
code stuff because there's not a lot of
help again and then the other part was
like obtaining a developer's license was
a bit difficult because these these
these companies are awfully I think
territorial about their EHRs and you
know I mean what did I learn it was like
you have to set goals that reflect the
maturity of the field you're working on
given that fire itself is a very recent
thing and more so for like things like
smart on fire I think it was a bit it
was a bit wrong for me to be so
ambitious and you know I think and I
think for anybody developing you have to
collaborate because that's the way you
get your ideas across and you get new
ideas and it really helps and yeah I
mean this was what I thought was gonna
be a seemingly straightforward project
it wasn't so straightforward but there
were lots of things that I learned and I
hope that you know you guys are able to
take at least some insight away from
away from what I've shared here and
these are the references that we use you
know thank you to the the National
Library of Medicine for allowing us to
actually do this internship under their
grant in their funding but also thank
you so much dr. eden dr. will dr. Nelson
everyone in this room everyone in the in
the department for allowing us to do
this
I mean spent a great time we've learned
so much so thank you so seriously thank
you so much and
[Music]
[Applause]
contribution and I know you sounded very
frustrated but before epic all the
mammography information was put into
something called mrs and we we had to
get an extensive effort to back engineer
that system because the industry just
locks it up they don't let you do what
you want with your own data so you know
there's a long track of the record of
this sort of thing and I am NOT they
bioinformatician other people in the
room are but it's really frustrating
people want to get clinical data on
their own patients and do work with that
so whatever baby steps we take are
really useful so don't be too frustrated
it's really helpful and to bring this
tool to the spanish-speaking women is
tremendous we felt we needed to do that
from the first day we worked on mammoth
screens so your work especially the
context of this stuff patients don't
understand risk anyway whatever language
you're in so to make that more
accessible to huge important populations
just great contributions so I'm really
glad you came and did this work thank
you so much I'd like to echo what dr.
Nelson said even though you may feel
like these are small steps these
actually are very important steps for
our project and and your information
will be information we can use in the
future so I just appreciate that I
appreciate the lessons learned and I'm
sure there's a few in this audience who
might echo some of your lessons learned
with their projects but also I just want
to re-emphasize that we appreciate the
work and the contribution that you've
made this summer and I don't know
whether Ben hasn't got another question
here whether Ben has questions about the
great job great presentation and project
so my question is for Gokul and I was
curious to know so if you were gonna
continue working on this project in the
future you had mentioned that there was
a group at Boston Children's in Harvard
who are working on like actually like
instructions and educational materials
for working on fire related projects and
you know what would you see as like a
new beginner
what resources would you be interested
in developing like documentation wise or
tutorials that you think would be most
useful to the community for other groups
or researchers in other informatics
programs to actually speed along the
process that it looks like was very
challenging for you you know I think
centrally the issue is not so much a
lack of resources in very specific
arenas but a lack of resources in
general and so it's difficult for me to
say specifically what would be required
when it's just an utter lack altogether
and you know I mean that's it's
understandable because of how recent
this is right like it makes sense but as
I think as this field develops and as
more and more people start coding in it
and you granted it'll be difficult to
get into it and and to actually do
things but that process might might slow
you might start slowly but it'll get
quicker and you know it's like as those
resources are spread and you know as
they're as they proliferate I think that
everybody will have an easier time
coding I mean as for like specifics I
would say like like you had you wrote up
you know these were the three okay
things that I found most useful
something like that that would be you
know if you were a new beginner and
another researcher who wanted to develop
um your translator or actually implement
decision aid or other fire happily this
is where you should begin kind of thing
and if you were to do this type of
project with some sort of tutorial that
sort of highlighted those like key
findings yeah be something that you
think oh absolutely right I mean the
hardest part is always start documenting
yeah correct and so and so I think yeah
I think if there were more resources out
there for like how did you get something
small right like I mean those methods
were fairly simple methods but like the
OAuth function that I mentioned like you
can't have a fire program without having
that method and it's like you need that
and so I I totally agree with you maybe
I know what I find helpful personally
not just in this regard but in any sort
of any sort of academic endeavors like
having a YouTube video too
- like to tell me like what I'm doing
cuz I don't know and so if there were
YouTube videos about this man I would be
very happy but unfortunately there
aren't so many but you know it's to be
expected but I'd like that would be
wonderful just like a YouTube playlist
like how to create an app and then it
shows you how to do yeah I hope I have
answered your question but this is I'm
Ben Orwell and I I totally feel your
pain I think you know we worked on this
early in the summer and and I think you
have learned a lot about this process
and you know have run up against a lot
of the same challenges that I've also
experienced and I'm sure that others
have and you know I hope that maybe this
is something that you'll think about
continuing to play around with in your
future and I know you haven't quite
figured out exactly like where you're
going but but I do think it's it's early
times and the documentation is very
scattered and sparse and that I hope
that efforts like these and and if we
continue to have success in the mammoth
screen project integrating this as a
fire application that that it will sort
of be a watershed and and sort of a dam
that opens up and a flood of kind of
applications and new ways of using these
kinds of patient data resources will be
available to people and I think one
thing that I hope over to the next few
years here is that we can really try to
create an environment that fosters
participation amongst the students and
the faculty and just the OHSU community
in this process because as you said it's
really frustrating when when companies
EHRs and and other groups try to
tightly control and lock down all of the
access to use data and and I think that
it's starting to open up and the best
way to get it to continue to open up is
to use it and try to push push the
limits and sort of say we're hitting
against this wall and we need you to
open it up more and and I hope that
that's gonna continue to happen so it
was I'm glad that you had an interesting
time and I'm really looking forward to
what we can do with with this in the
future
nice work you two it's a really good
presentation so question for Gokul so
say someone you use Cerner with this
project but say someone a twit just you
wanted this right and we use epic here
what challenges would you foresee in
having to translate all of the stuff
that you did into epic so presumably the
only difference would be getting access
to an epic sandbox I think it's called
like app garden or something like that
is that the doctor was that correct for
it for epic app app orchard that's what
it's yeah so so like in theory nothing
would be the different because like like
fire and so on fire is supposed to like
their motto is plug in and play you
should be able to switch EHR seamlessly
so like what I'm thinking now is there
should be no issue until you do it you
won't notice the issue so like honestly
like I I'm saying this now but like
don't hold me to it so like there there
might be a lot of issues but in theory
there's an issue yeah so I think that's
a good point like in theory there you
know if you tried to look into the
future there might not be but then I
think it's also interesting that like
Cerner and epic do play differently like
for example if you're looking for
certain keywords or terms or you know
variables within Cerner that they might
not exist in epics like that might be
one thing that you might have a
challenge with you might change your
code and like in theory smart on fire is
supposed to be you know the most
interval thing yeah like you just use it
once and done but I think as you've said
before like there's not many resources
so people probably have to still figure
out what yeah needs to be done in each
environment but yeah you guys did a
really nice job this summer
very useful in the future as we go on
and I think it should be usable in any
of the regions that you choose to
implement
I mean one of the biggest differences
was the time they had those that were
younger usually tended to have kids and
so the the worries that they had what
they cared about the they care more
about the position aid and the the
options he gave on what was important to
them and the older people cared a little
bit more about the risk assessment and
their family history and how that would
possibly affect their own children I so
I have a question actually for I am
amazing work both of you and you know
medical translation is a very tricky
field right and the literature is
replete with articles on how poorly
people do I love what you've done and
I'm really interested in hearing the
process that you went through I wanted
to ask you if you're planning to share
this in a publication somewhere so that
it could be perhaps used to develop that
tool in other languages some of these
things that you've described sound like
they you know they would work in other
ethnic groups or you know in other
languages as well do you have plans on
sort of working in that field a little
bit more or publishing as of currently
no I hadn't thought of that
but as I've been working with this
project I've definitely tried looking up
articles on the subject and yeah they
vary and in the topics they they they
talk about and yeah there's no set
format I tried looking for formats and
like guides to Paul and there really
wasn't much I know that I definitely
would have appreciated having some sort
of structure to go off of
so if possible I think I would like to
to leave some sort of
trampoline bellows can jump off of and
like get a head start so in the future
yes that might be something I pursue
I had on another I had a question for IO
host if you could speak to you had
mentioned that you know there's lots of
dialects of Spanish and sort of what
your approach was for the translations
you worked on did you use like your
intuition and the dialects that you were
most familiar with did you try to find
like meanings of words that were
consistent across all that Alex you're
familiar with just speaking a little bit
about that like cross-checking of you
know the basically using words that have
the you know the most number of people
probably have the same intuition about
what they mean yeah so the first time
that I started translating it was really
just on what I was familiar with and
what I knew however as I interviewed
people and talked to more people I
definitely took their thoughts on
account and I try to find different
people from different backgrounds so
that I could get as big of a sample as I
could with a diverse sample and that
have different opinions on the words and
I try to keep it as the language is
basic as I could sometimes for example
screen there's an actual word for it in
Spanish however most people wouldn't
know like what it was yeah and so
descriptions had to be used and there's
still definitely like some I just based
on what I was going to say in the
dictionary
a dictionary has a word and then it has
the yeah so yeah so there's definitely
like some words for that should have an
extra meaning attached to it like an
extra description of the meaning I know
that that's something that in the
English version mammogram there's we
have we have that and I unfortunately
wasn't able to work on that on
translating that but that's definitely
something that I think would further
help fix that and be witty going forward
all right thank you
[Applause]
so good morning my name is Joe Nash and
I have the pleasure of introducing
Keaton Whitaker who was working with me
and the team that is doing a study of
scribing he's been working with us over
the summer I should tell you a little
bit about him he is going into his
junior year at Berkeley UC Berkeley he's
majoring he has a double major in public
health and oratory and when I asked him
about that during the interview he said
well oratory is all about persuasion and
we need more of that in public health so
it makes perfect sense he has he
actually came to us with some research
experience both at Stanford and at
Berkeley in the public health arena and
so he has a solid background in
quantitative methods but again I was
recruiting someone for qualitative work
which is what our team needed and he
said well I have done a little
qualitative work and I really want to
learn more about it and I'm very
interested in mixed methods and I
thought this is the perfect candidate
right so he's been working with us over
the summer to develop a Delphi study and
he'll tell you more about it and how
that fits into the overall work that
we've been doing introduction thank you
for the opportunity to work with you
this summer I really enjoyed the work I
got to do and I'm excited to present it
here so my presentation today focuses on
the Delphi method and how it applies to
scribing I'll start off by exploring the
field describing a little bit in the
background - it's going into the
different methods that are needed to
approach a field like scribing and I
feel like informatics in general and
then talking specifically about the
Delphi method and the Delphi technique
and the intricacies of that and then how
he applied the Delphi method to study
ascribing for dr. Ash's
and I don't know why the slides aren't
quite configured but we'll see if that
gets better before we can talk about
scribes we actually have to go back and
talk about the electronic health record
or the EHR since doctors have been
slowly switching over to the electronic
health record from paper records and
there's a lot of great things that have
come along with the EHR including better
care and the ability to care for
patients better but there's also been a
lot of unintended consequences that have
been studied by dr. Ashton or colleagues
these include if clinician is using the
EHR then they spend a lot more time
inputting patient data into the computer
they have less time or less eye contact
with patients and then there's an
overall burden on the provider that
really has promoted physician burnout
and that's been a big problem there's
been a few ways to kind of circumvent
these issues that have arisen with the
EHR to really untether the provider from
having to be the input of all this
information and one proposed solution to
this problem is to use medical scribes a
medical scribe being an unlicensed
individual that's hired by the clinician
to input patient data under their
supervision and allow them to not be so
burdened by the EHR since the EHRs knew
this idea of using medical scribes to
take notes and enter data is also pretty
new in 2014 there were less than 20,000
scribes in United States and then by
2020 there's projected to be over a
hundred thousand so this field its
medical scribing is the fastest growing
profession in medicine right now by 2020
there's expect to be one scribe for
every nine physicians out there and
along with this there's also 22 scribing
companies that train scribes and develop
scribes that can go work for doctors and
be a scribe in the medical field but
since it's so new these scribes are not
well studied well understood and as a
result they are unregulated in a lot of
places but then even more important than
that is that how do we know that scribes
are the band-aid that's going to fix
this problem with the EHR how do we know
that medical scribes are the solution
and that they're not going to falter
with the technical difficulties and the
frustrations of using the EHR that
clinicians have run into that nurses
have run into that mas I've grown into
what makes scribes so special about and
being trained and using this EHR that
has kind of given some other people so
much grief to approach a field like
scribing or like informatics though um
you can't just rely on one form of study
I'm from a very quantitative background
that's where a lot of my research has
been done before and that's what I'm
familiar with working as data with
native data as number sets it's deducted
you can test theories its objective
generalizable and comfortable consistent
but taking a step back from that if you
don't have the chance to actually use
quantitative data if there's no
opportunity to generate quantitative
data you really have to start from
qualitative data which is what you use
as an inductive research type to build
theories that you can eventually test
later qualitative data is is very
different than quantitative just in its
nature it's subjective it contextual and
I come from a place where quantitative
data is very privileged over qualitative
data and that's considered the gold
standard but coming into a field where I
know who's going to be working with
qualitative data it's important to not
read these lists as the strengths of
quantitative data alone but these are
two different lists of strengths of
different research methods so you're
going to use different parts of these
lists to get at your research project
and they're just different ways of
seeking the truth as you're conducting
research but since I'm unfamiliar with
qualitative research I had a few hurdles
to overcome when working with data as
interviews and words instead of number
sets and the big one is is finding
confidence real confidence in
qualitative data because it's not as
consistent it's contextual and
subjective so I had the opportunity to
work on a few other projects on the side
for dr. Ashe and I got to code some
interviews and other pieces of
qualitative data and these are the big
takeaways for me that helped me get real
confident with qualitative data the
first is that all qualitative research
is hermeneutic in its approach that
means all the knowledge you construct
for your research is based on the text
and a conversation that the researcher
is having with the text it's very
grounded theory so you're always going
to end
refer back to the actual data that you
collected in order to make your theories
and find your patterns next is that
there is coding involve a qualitative
data although it's very separate from
quantitative coding or computer coding I
think the best way to think about it is
it's sorting patterns that you see in
the interviews and looking at theories
that come up in reoccurrences in all of
your interviews across interviews and
across sites and developing those
patterns into theories and for your
findings so when you're coding and when
you're looking for these patterns that
is a big analysis part it takes being
active and really paying attention to
what you're reading to make those
analyses and then the the other part is
that when you code you code in teams or
dyads dydz of their teams of two or
sometimes you code in bigger teams so
you always have someone else to
cross-reference your work check what
you're doing and see that patterns are
consistently being built out of these
data sets but with informatics it
doesn't just take quantitative or
qualitative it is a mix of both and when
you do mix methods research it's not a
willy-nilly mix of just quantitative and
qualitative there's a very there's a
pragmatic approach to it where you're
really trying to select the strengths
from both of those different types of
research to create the methods that's
going to get at the heart of your
research the best so when you are
conducting this type of research there's
a huge focus on the link between yeah
your procedure and why are actually
conducting that procedure what you're
hoping to get out of that and out of
those forms of research and then lastly
makes methods research it's fairly new
and it's becoming more and more accepted
and more and more established journals
are more frequently accepting
qualitative papers and mixed methods
papers but they always require a
justification of why they chose to do
certain methods be they quantitative or
qualitative and what those methods did
to serve their research purpose so I've
been reading up on a lot of mixed
methods and doing a lot of work with
them and I've they come up a lot for me
this summer so in all of our
Thursday meetings where we had people
come present to us I found examples of
mixed methods research that really stuck
out to me and there's just different
organizations of these quantitative and
qualitative structures mixing and
matching these different methods and
then when you mix and match you do get
to these specific strengths of these
studies we're having a qualitative first
and then a quantitative can give you a
certain edge on what you're trying to
research so if you have a preliminary
qualitative study that leads into a big
quantitative study that's a really good
way to generate hypotheses potentially
for future testing Peter graven who came
ere dr. Peter graven that came to talk
to us last week at the end he talked a
lot about establishing causality through
epidemiologic methods and a really key
way to do that is to first do a
qualitative study to suss out potential
confounding factors in epidemiologic
tools before we move on to your heavy
quantitative study if you flip that
instead you have a quantitative analysis
that leads into a core qualitative study
that's a really good way to like look at
subgroups and then get into the big
piece that you want to study dr. Michael
Chang came to talk to us and he in his
talk he mentioned the paper from dr.
pamela patel and she looked at dr. notes
before and after the implementation of
the EHR and that was her qualitative
piece but before she did that she really
looked at numbers of diagnoses from
different note structures and how often
certain types of information were
included in EHR notes verses and
handwritten notes if you have follow-up
studies instead a core study followed by
a core quantitative study followed by a
follow-up qualitative study for example
that is a really good way to explore
significant with outsiders or just any
anomalies you might find in your data
set and what a great example I found of
that was the work of dr. Eden dr. Nelson
and whose interns just presented but
they with their app that they're
developing and they ran their
quantitative tests and then with
follow-up interviews the women that used
the app they found out that um they had
already planned on being screened prior
to that study and that was a really key
piece of information that
used a better that work and then
flipping that one more time a core
qualitative going into a consular study
that's a great example of the Delphi
method where you're trying to develop
measures of key concepts and then
hopefully testing them later and the
Delphi method is what I get to go into
now the Delfin method is what I got to
work with this summer
it takes its name from the Oracle of
Delphi if anyone read Percy Jackson
growing up you might be familiar with
did you might be familiar with the
Oracle of Delphi it's from Greek
mythology in ancient Greece the Oracle
was the High Priestess of the temple of
apollo and they were thought to be able
to predict the future so people would
come to them to get predictions about
what would happen historians think that
maybe the Delphi um used natural signs
to predict the future and just make
broad statements but that's where our
study gets the name because the Delphi
method it's its purpose is to make
predictions and forecasts about the
future of certain fields the Delphi
method gets its power from a panel of
experts in the field that make these
predictions with the help of the
research formats and the big things that
come out of the Delphi study are
identification of important issues in a
field and then secondly and it yields a
lot of qualitative data that can be
worked with to make further inquiry into
the field or into a place of study and
this is key because Delphi studies are
typically used when not a lot of
information is known about a field and
it's the first step into making broader
explorations into an area that hasn't
really been studied before this is the
general pattern of how a Delphi method
runs although there's variations that
you make according to each specific
study that you do so it all starts with
brainstorming and defining a general
problem in a field which is done by
usually the investigators and the
panelists the expert panelists together
after the expert panelists have been
assembled and then you go into your
rounds of surveys what's unique about
the Delphi is that all the experts never
actually have to meet the all of the
rounds of inquiry are done through
surveys that are sent from the
researcher to the expert panels which is
nice because it's a little bit cheaper
that way but after you brainstorm the
problem you go to round one in which you
take all the list of the big list of
issues and you narrow them
down so each expert panelists will have
a chance to confirm the list of issues
add to the list of issues change it or
suggest modifications to it in general
after you have your set list of issues
down you move on to round 2 which is
ranking the importance of these issues
to the field in the near future
after you rank them then it's up to the
researchers to establish concordance
among those rankings if they find
concordance concordance then awesome
they did it and they can publish the
findings but if they didn't then they go
back and revise their survey rounds
revise their ranking round to either
better explain their issues to hopefully
establish importance so this all looks
great and but it's not very
straightforward it can get a little bit
messy sometimes and it kind of got it
really hope I started to wonder what's
the purpose of doing all this like why I
don't just have a random person come in
and predict the future is that any
different from what we're doing here and
it reminded me of this great quote the
Oracle of Delphi didn't know crap
anybody can get high and predict the
future and it really stuck actually
because I just want to make a hard
distinction and a draw a hard line
between just random predictions and what
the actual use of going through all of
the roundabout of the Delphi is and
there's a few big key strengths to the
Delphi and the first is the expert
panelists these expert panelists are not
just the phd's although you can't have
PhDs on your panel it's a diverse range
of people that all know a lot a lot
about the issue that can be on the
ground working in the field and studying
different aspects of the field and your
goal is to get a very big and broad look
at the issue from your expert panelists
the second is that your experts are
anonymous to each other and this is
really key because then there's no
opportunity for group thing group think
to take over there's no mob mentality
the loudest voice in the room doesn't
win the prettiest voice doesn't win the
richest voice doesn't win it's
everyone's voice gets the same
consideration the same opportunity to
make an impact on this study the big
thing about the Delphi I guess I should
a little bit reframe it it's not about
predicting the future it's about
identifying key issues for the future
and that's something useful you can take
away
out of a study because these issues are
both the input and the output of Adelphi
and then lastly it does help you build
theory about what's really going on in a
field which is a big aspect of why Delta
Phi's are actually becoming more popular
there's been a lot more published in
recent years I'm forever the skeptic so
I kind of wanted to go back and look at
Delphi studies that had worked or had
and made an impact so in 2004 there was
a study done on nurse informations about
what skills nurses really need to know
in relation to informatics and this has
been a big study in this field
informatics particularly there's a lot
of Delphi studies going on in
informatics and in Health Sciences right
now just because it's a fast-growing
field and it's important to know and be
able to predict upcoming or arising
issues or where the fields going and the
second one is it was a Delphi it was a
2004 study out of Hawaii in the
communications field and what they did
is they looked at a Delphi that was
published 16 years prior and then they
measured the predictions made by that
Delfi Delphi and with what was actually
happening the field today and they found
most of the predictions that were made
16 years ago to be highly accurate and
then lastly the Delphi on academic
Health Sciences done in the 1980s has is
very relevant to what we do actually
here because that Delphi was used to
secure some funding to start information
Sciences program here at OHSU and the
funding from that grant actually helped
to build the building we're in today and
to start the demise program so we all
have a Delphi to thank for this
internship this summer or partially to
bank going back to the work I'd got to
do this summer was applying this Delphi
method to scribing so there's a few
modifications that we made because
that's what you do in mixed methods
research because you really want to fit
the process to what you're trying to
study and what you're trying to get at
so first off you have we changed it from
issues involved with scribing to TAS
involve ascribing caste standing for
knowledge attitudes and skill
subscribes because we're not concerned
with the scribing industry we don't
necessarily need to know where that's
going we need to know how scribes are
going to better serve clinicians through
being competent the ultimate goal with
this is to take these competencies that
we built to the input and output of the
Delphi study and develop them into
training modules so that we can be sure
that these scribes that are going into
the field are there and able to serve
the physicians so that the physicians
can better do their work and then
secondly there's actually two separate
Delphi survey lists that are currently
being sent out one really the de general
work for scribes which is just being a
member of a medical team and being able
to work well in that environment and
then another survey that is specifically
related to the EHR and the ability and
skill set to navigate the EHR input it
and be the master of the EHR so that the
clinician really doesn't have to worry
about that and for our study the
selection of experts was really really
wide and dr. Ashe was in charge of
making that list narrowing that down and
finally collecting these experts but
they do come from all different fields
and they're experts not necessarily
inscribing although some of them are but
they're experts in the scribe provider
EHR interaction because that's what
we're interested in that's where these
consequences have arisen and that's what
we really need to get at if we're gonna
end if this Delphi is really going to
serve our intended purpose so back to
this model dr. Ashe held all the
brainstorming for this big list of tasks
initially and then the work I did this
summer was going from that step to round
one so taking all this big lists of
tasks 89 in total and then translating
them into a survey for all of the
experts to see and have a chance to
modify add subtract anything they want
before that list of Casas finalized
after that
now we're hopefully that survey has now
been sent out and we're in the process
of collecting that data from the experts
after we collect that back we'll send
out the second round of survey so that
these experts can rank the importance of
these tasks and then once they return
that it's up to the researchers to
establish concordance among those
rankings
and if not then we'll have to go back
and remodel I our survey but if we do
then we can make some judgments off of
our findings in this round one this is
an example of a cast included in the
general survey for the cognition of
scribes any scribe needs to have mental
stamina that's the basic cast and then
with every cast we also included a
meaning so that every expert that reads
this is sure of what that cast is
intended to mean and with this they are
given three multiple choice options they
can keep this pass or they can not keep
or change this cast and if they choose
to not keep her change then we ask them
their reasoning so that we can track why
they chose to certain things and
incorporate that into our study as well
and additionally they're allowed to add
any casts so that we can have a full and
complete record of the cast that these
experts think are important to the field
after that in round two of the ranking
aspect once that's all ranked the big
tool that's used to assess this ranking
I'm sorry about these slides but is
Kendall's W coefficient for concordance
so it looks like a big square equation
but what really what it really comes
down to is that you put all the expert
rankings into that equation if w equals
zero then that means no expert agree
with any other experts they were all
incredibly different it's a nightmare
and you also probably did something
wrong because that's not likely to
happen a expert should have some degree
of concordance with them likewise if w
equals one then every researcher agreed
on every single ranking you've performed
an absolute miracle and he also probably
did something wrong because that's not
going to happen either more than likely
your w is going to fall in the middle
range and the number you're looking for
is 0.7 generally it's accepted that if
your W is above 0.7 then you can say
that you've established concordance and
you can move on to handling your results
any scrub these are two examples from
the EHR component any scribe needs to be
familiar with templates and any scribe
needs to be able to track provider
corrections in the EHR it's a little bit
hard to give theoretical predictions
about how these will be ranked but and
hopefully with the ranking you'd be able
to say something along the lines of X
percentage of experts agreed that one
cast was X
percentage more important than the other
although there's a plethora of different
ways that you can quantitatively present
your rankings going back to the purpose
for all this study the big end goal is
to develop competencies for scribes for
this Delphi study which will serve the
greater purpose of developing training
modules for these scribes that hopefully
they can use to be better prepared to go
into the field so currently we're on the
second block on our way to making these
training modules but it's an important
step because we need to make sure that
the scribes that are going into the
field are accurately trained and
appropriately trained so that they can
untether the provider from the EHR and
the e and the provider can continue to
give the good quality that they know how
to give so thank you so much for
listening and I hope we have time for a
few questions if they're out there
[Applause]
thank you for that great presentation
explaining the Delphi method I got to
participate in the Delphi method about
ten years ago when we were any
international body forming standards for
how to develop decision aids and what
the content should be and I will tell
you it was very messy at the beginning
we came started with this big huge long
list of standards and did a lot of uh
did a lot of refinement it was a lot of
dialogue but what came out of it are a
set of a checklist of standards so it
was important work it doesn't happen
instantly though it we probably took a
year to of different part rounds and
iterations and repeating things so I
think you're learning quite a bit and
most of us are also quantitative people
with some qualitative training so we
were all having to you know learn to
with this Delphi processes
thanks for this when you were showing
that diagram you talked a little bit
about what happens when folks don't come
to consensus and I and I wondered
especially when you have a single person
like dr. Ashe you know selecting the
experts the area of scribing is
certainly an area where I think there's
people who think scribes are a way to go
with this problem but a lot of people
also think kind of how much can you go
with automating this so instead of
inserting another human how do you go in
terms of automating this process and so
I'd be curious about whether whether
this is with your project or with your
background reading where you saw
thoughts about including experts who
actually have fairly divergent opinions
at the beginning and how do you actually
deal in your Delphi with where people
don't come to consensus recognizing that
that is an actual reportable important
finding that different groups think
differently about this particular part
of this work question and and one of the
big strengths of the Delphi is that
there is definitely room to report
outliers like that if you do have these
big differences in the best way to solve
this
EHR problem and one of the big things
going back to just the very beginning of
deciding whether or not to go ascribes
or something else is that scribes are
sometimes by a lot of people actually
looked at as more of a short-term
solution short term being until the EHR
is at the point where providers
themselves can just input that
information directly and skip the scribe
the medical scribe hopefully entirely so
when you're talking about and the the
competencies that scribes are supposed
to develop for these modules yes these
and this is looking at the immediate
future because we know that the EHR is
not really going to get to a point where
it can just be the provider for awhile I
mean I'm not sure about the exact
forecast for that but I know it's out
there and I know that people are also
looking out for that to happen so in
that it's looking at once that once the
EHR is at that level where providers
don't necessarily need an assistant to
input that what then does the role of
the scribe become are they obsolete or
is there still room for them to assist
with documentation or
the betterment of the healthcare process
in some regard and if I if I can put
this in a little more context I was not
the only one selecting the expert panel
everyone on our research team helped and
in particular Jeff Gould and Vishnu but
also Dean city for example I asked some
people who know a lot of people we
started with a list we wanted some
professional associations represented so
we asked someone from the AMA and we got
a vice president to come who christine
sinski who has written quite a bit about
scribing we wanted someone from the
double-a MC etc etc then we wanted
providers we wanted representatives of
scribes we wanted industry and that was
so interesting because we did get a
representative from scribe America and a
representative from scribe X we so we
did invite about 30 people from all
different roles to be part of the expert
panel and to go back even further the
original list of competencies was based
on the field work we had done at five
sites around the country where we were
gathering best practices and we did our
analysis of all of the interviews and
field notes looking for competencies
there we did a literature search about
competencies and then we had a
conference and at the conference and it
was the same expert so they they know
who they are but they don't know what
input they're giving during these
distance survey pieces so at the
conference and he knows a lot about this
because he got to analyze the conference
proceedings which are crazy when you've
got 30 experts talking and for each of
the competences when he put it into the
survey
he read the transcripts to see what they
said so that the wording would be as
they wanted it and not as I wanted it or
as Keaton wanted it so I hope that helps
yeah thanks for clarifying
so I mean this entire thing could be
going way over my head so just stop me
if I'm asking a terrible question but
I'm curious how does like the time scale
of your study affect how likely like
your experts are to conform like well I
know it's like anonymous but like how
like how many rounds did you have to go
through like does that make sense like
yeah no that's that's a really good
question and an attrition of experts is
a really big deal in any study but with
the Delphi study you're really lucky to
have these experts that have that are
given their time to the study so you do
want to treat them actually really well
when you're sending out these surveys so
the first thing is that the surveys are
meticulously designed so that it's the
least amount of effort on the people
that are filling them out so that means
that that you really have to be
streamlined with it so it doesn't take
too much of their time because otherwise
they're less likely to finish it and
you're less likely to get the data but
after that so it's the first round and
the second round of the mandatory ones
and you do ask them for their reasoning
behind their choices so that you can
collect some of that data too but you're
absolutely right you don't want to
overburden your experts here with
unnecessary steps and you won't keep
repeating this round after round after
round after a certain point you've
collected the data you can and people
are set in their ways and you're not
just aiming for concordance the whole
time that's that's the happy result that
happens if you don't establish
concordance then you still accumulated
hopefully a lot of qualitative data to
look through anyway but you shouldn't be
exhausting your experts to the point
where they're out
all right well thank you so much I sold
[Applause]